[Musik]
ja also und sagte dennis irgendwas
eingebrochen also und
vielleicht auch die aktion von den
kirchen uhr ja die sind auf uns
zugekommen echte komme weil er sonst ist
man ja jetzt wird man manchmal wirklich
überraschen aber wir sollten das
wirklich auf 10 wie wir wirklich rein
legen würden das mitbekommt was wirkt
vorhaben
machen
und einen vorhand-ball band ok menschen
erzählen wir irgendwie keine ahnung
led paneele aber dann passt das so
richtig auf keine ahnung ebenso ein
geschäftsmann nach von keine ahnung
irgendwoher über gespannt wo heute
hingehen ich weiß noch gar nichts davon
ich weiß was er hat uns im prinzip nur
erzählt der strecke neuer technologie
und eben was mit leinwand
ein anderer ex managers mit hat
irgendwas von dubai erzählt das team
kommt aus dubai eines europäers kommt
aus dubai was windows dubai kommt man
mal ganz ehrlich keiner weise
lassen sich am besten reinlegen wir
waren irgendwie nach winnenden rund 6
wir machen einfach so bin
ja
jetzt mal ehrlich jetzt mal ohne spaß
sechs oder
siebenjähriger habe er nichts anderes
gewohnt als geschirrtücher
nach frittierfett
machst du die geschichte ich tue so als
müsste ich von nichts und dann und dann
spiele ich einfach mittag liegt in
[Musik]
der wirtschaft noch gucken
ich glaube die rutschte das herz in die
hose nico verarscht mich nicht
ehrlich jetzt werde jetzt schauen wir
schauen jetzt
mal ohne spaß jetzt aber sie ist schon
gewaltig was
die haben gesagt es nur eine halle und
da drin sind stabil schirm draußen und
drinnen
[Musik]
muss ich ihm im rat bist du dass herr
gott macht der hand weg
[Musik]
ihr seid doch blöd oder ihr seid das
wasser bescheuert
sogar immer du hast nicht warst du hast
nicht verarscht ist doch immer kärcher
tag ja wie ist denn ihr habt mich echt
verarscht
ach gott dem moritz nach gott wir sind
kirche sind alle da ach gott hatte mich
verarscht heute fast wie bei kärcher
wusste vorstand nur auf servus
christlich willkommen beim
weltmarktführer
ich hoffe das ok du wohl das klappt
eigentlich auch drin den windigen
investor treffen ja so 3d sie so blöd
sein und jetzt beim wenn ich halte
darüber verteidigungstechnik gelandet
ich hoffe das war okay für dich hab ich
mal beim wenigen investor der sehr
irgendwelche dinge geplant hat so eine
wand und dennis otto iv er hat mir noch
gesagt der kommt aus dubai der sag ich
was für technologie kommt denn aus dubai
ach da hier schon merken müssen
reinigungstechnik aus dem schwarm also
ich komme bei der firma kermi
morath wenn ich euch in unserer kirche
experience center bieten dürfte das war
alles geplant
ich würde ich jetzt am anfang mal
mitnehmen unsere meilensteine der
firmengeschichte wie alles begann wo wir
her kamen genau du weißt ja viel über
unsere firma ich glaube das meiste weiß
meine frau weiß aber nicht ich hoffe
trotzdem dass wir noch das eine oder
andere schmankerl dabei ist das für dich
neu ist
[Musik]
ja hier sehen wir nämlich wie alles
begann es begann auch nicht hier in
winnenden es begann in bad cannstatt von
stuttgart da fing alles an unsere
firmengründer alfred kärcher 1935 die
firma gegründet und ganz wichtig zu
wissen ob es begann nicht mit
reinigungstechnik sondern mit
heiztechnologie wenn es irgendwo eine
ein technisches problem gab dafür eine
lösung zu finden das war afrikas leben
darin dass aufgegangen dann sehen wir
hier eine ganz fette überschrift
einstieg ins privatkundengeschäft
1984 mit dem ersten tragbaren
hochdruckreiniger der welt im
555 mhd 15 gibt es doch immer noch
5 gibt es ja die nomen kato haben heute
noch denn das erste gerät ist hd 5550
der erste tragbare hochdruckreiniger
gerätes enorm erfolgreich auf dem markt
angekommen ist dass es damals doch
bisschen überrascht hatte aber der
grundstein dafür dass wir heute auch im
privatkundenbereich unterwegs sind gelb
auf anthrazit von unseren bekannten
kärcher gelb 13 18 cent gelb das ist wie
die mitternachts formel früher in der
schule wenn mich nachts der
geschäftsführer anruft dann wird mich
fragen was ist unsere farbe und dann
muss das wie aus der pistole geschossen
kommen also wenn das bei uns anfangen
möchtest merkt das schon mal 13 18
zinkmarkt gelb technik und innovation
morath damals die meisten awards
gewonnen und das ist kein zufall
es gibt kein reinigungsunternehmen der
welt das so innovativ unterwegs ist wie
wir momentan über 640 aktive patente da
gibt es niemand mit so viel patenten
hinsichtlich der reinigungstechnik ja
würde ich sagen gehen wir weiter und
werfen einen blick in die angesprochenen
entwicklungsabteilungen
[Musik]
schon monat von haben uns als bild
gesehen hier in original wenn es mal
anfassen möchte statt erst der
hochdruckreiniger heißwasser
hochdruckreiniger denn unser
firmengründer alfred kärcher den
fünfziger und entwickelt hat kommt einer
revolution
da in den 70ern die frau mit dem kärcher
und bei uns ist
ja das hat mich morgens sage jetzt mal
das hat sich auch geändert pulver er
dass er die die frau das sinnbild von
reinigen saubermachen und heute ist mehr
muss lauten hier ist relativ laut
unseren teststrecke
wir sind uns auch schon entwicklung
angelangt und wir haben jetzt hier fünf
verschiedenen teststrecken wir versuchen
ja die realität zu simulieren so nah wie
möglich an die realität hinzukommen was
du hast sie sind zum beispiel in der
mitte kopfsteinpflaster unebene unter
kunden wir schauen wie reagieren die
geräte wenn sie den ganzen tag
durchgeschüttelt werden
[Musik]
wenn wir jetzt wir gehen jetzt ins labor
inschallah labor ja welche knopfdrücke
möglich den klick hören also ich hab
einen klick hat ja da gibt es diesen
klick oder es gibt es blinkt und ich
möchte es klick haben und das ist und
dass das cliq sich gut anhört er dafür
sind die jungs verantwortlich
als unser schallaburg
können wir gerade ein oder hat schon die
messung laufen
perfekt unterbricht extra kurz vor und
seine arbeit aber ein raum den ich euch
nicht vorenthalten möchte hier sind es
wirklich im herzen der entwicklung es
geht um schall design ziemlich spacige
raum noch mal nichts anfassen
soll ich denn schaumschläger
das hat lange hoben mit dem nichts
einfach gott was ich schon displays und
so fühlt sich an denn das anfassen
jaja
elastisch in den himmel gesichtet raum
jedes youtube instagram in florenz was
hier bilder zu machen oh
mein gott oh mein gott
was
hörst du das ich höre gar nichts das ist
so als ich meine stimme schlucken
gut ich war noch nie auf sicher voll
abgespeist also ich war noch nie auf lsd
aber wenn das lsd sein dann sind so aus
wie
ein wirklich spezieller raum hier unser
sound labor
ich habe mich noch nie so reden gehört
dass vorabgespräch das ist auch voll
abgespeist sie ist moritz
[Musik]
humor
gemacht
[Musik]
seine sachen schon
sehr viel scheu ab gerade jetzt wichtig
nur schlimmer
[Musik]
das ist
ja viel applaus
bekommen sie die ausgegraben die preise
diesen typen ich kann dir keine angst
der ist nicht aus ihrem haus
ausgebrochen einfach ist wie es ist wenn
ich komme mir diese candyman sein
kollege mir dass ich dich jetzt bei
kärcher die systeme von gleicher wie
sehr ich sag's dir war man noch uns
warum warum ist wie ich bin das
testimonial von werden wir sehen
was jetzt kommen ja auch keiner klar
jeder kirche qualität wer billig kauft
kauft zweimal sagen und die zahl wird
ist alles hier mal
da kommt man zu so dass philipp da hat
sich bereit erklärt bei 23 meter noch
mit mir uns mit kommen würde wir haben
eine kleine wette mit ihr vor
[Musik]
wir machen auch jeden mist der gegner
sich jetzt rächen geht deswegen war
deswegen ist der philipp da okay murat
natürlich kann so eine chance selber
gesagt dein outfit wenn du vor was
gewusst hätte ich ja wirklich immer
umzogen jetzt möchten sie die chance
geben
sich
in die garderobe und
herrscht im einzel sondern ist
doch ich weiß ihr seid so irre wenn es
irgend was okay denn es zeigen bitte die
garderobe ok kommen ihr habt immer sehr
schwierig mache ich fertig
der soll die kamera ausmachen jetzt sein
doch die soll sich ausmachen
ich würde es irgendwie sich aus wie so
eine hummel oder so
minimal auf gleichzeitig an die
einfachheit da denke ich mache mir geld
alles ja die augenärzte
in schöne das macht mir macht das ding
ich höre in 100 jahren nicht ich bin des
mannes
wusste also
das ist doch
kein bist du bescheuert hör auf es ist
ein banner die weiß ich wer sich nicht
an die augenbinde ist da zu wenig um
augen
damals sah aber
wir haben wir haben was andere das für
dich zum anziehen ich mache das nicht
ich hab's gewusst ich hab echt jetzt mal
ist es so ernst dass
sie an
gott du kannst die rose an lassen jetzt
sei die hose schon ausgezahlt nach ja
nicht auch bleiben das neue feature
machen mich auf mach ja nicht nein
verdammt echt bestätigt zu fragen
die decke blödmann
jetzt sollte noch englisch umfassen wir
haben halt nichts mehr im kader sieht so
aus ja fast kicker
[Gelächter]
jetzt bei schiene runterrutschen dass
die zigarren du musst nur dass ich jetzt
über draußen fangen
mache ich mich nicht noch jemand ernst
ja alle gelacht
ist es noch nun ja leider passt wie
angegossen jungen hatten alle spaß jetzt
ja
[Musik]
schlag den raab wir haben einige
challenges heute vorbereitet natürlich
murat kaya ich werde dich nach köln
schicken da komme ich nie mehr wieder
zurück schwabenländle das ist allerdings
waren sie werden wir gleich sehen du
sagst du bist größte kärcher film den es
jemals gegeben hat ja es wird sich also
natürlich jetzt um kärcher drehen hast
du trainiert so ehrlich und
die erste challenge wir waren vor im
sound labor der geräusch unsere geräte
ist kein zufall ja und wir haben alle
noch dieses geräusch man die augen
schließen von dem fc im hinterkopf wir
sind wie ein hochdruckreiniger sich
anhört samstags in der nachbarschaft ja
und so was ähnliches machen wir jetzt
auch es geht darum die geräte unserer
firma an geräusch zu erkennen bedeutet
einer von euch beiden bekommen jetzt
erstmal micky maus ohren auf er wird
sagen philipp den partner im stummer
moderator tritt ja woran erkennst du
kirche geredet hier klar haben wir uns
auch in der fabrik ok alles leid dass
wir den scheiß machen und dass du den
scheiß mit mach ich ja schon in ordnung
gerade
meine schockiert ist sowas macht auch
uns spaß macht deswegen würde ich sagen
niemals platz auf der couch einer von
euch beiden bekommt mit dem autoren in
dem genau und murat mit ihr fang mal an
du schaust strikt in diese richtung und
in deinem hintergrund wenn man dann
nacheinander verschiedene kirchen geräte
anstatt bringen und du sonst an um was
es sich handelt ganz klar die spielregel
wer am ende mehr geräte richtig erkannt
hat hat die challenge gewonnen ich liebe
sie ist der nicht mehr weiß was ein
reinigungsgerät ich das match fit wäre
schon 15 dynastie der hyksos ja genau
das noch nie wieder einiges gerät
gesehen also ich gesagt ja ich weiss
nicht meinen freitag der ausarbeitung
ich durfte erst mal die straße fegen
nicht jeder kann da ist es jeden freitag
gewesen aber im wesentlichen
auf
ok
was wir euch jetzt noch erzählen müssen
wir haben natürlich die ganzen
challenges ein bisschen gepimpt das
heißt morath kann gar nicht gewinnen
murat wird gnadenlos verlieren weil
jeder gegner der da ist vorbereitet ist
die antworten schon kennt alles
auswendig weiß und murat wirklich
einfach nur scheiße wird sowie das
verdient
[Gelächter]
braucht gar nicht gucken
100 prozent würde sich der w3 der sich
der akku sauger vom fenster das höre ich
an dem an der hohl kammer höre ich das
hundertprozentig
mir ganz ganz sicher wenn das nicht
stimmt gehe ich sofort raus
gebe ich alles auch wenn das nicht der
hand ab zürich da meist ich auch nicht
der akku soll jacko sauger oder
prozentig garantiert wd irgendwas dann
waren uns dann ganz nah dran aber ein
staubsauger 100 fenster sauger war schon
mal nicht ganz so schlecht das war der
wg fünf jahre es ist der bv stv 6
stimmen haben wir sechs jahre aber es
war nicht ich das sagen oder fenster
sauger könne ja weil es das erste gerät
war aber jetzt ein bisschen
konzentrieren www ddv das sind ja ganz
andere welten ja ich weiß mir leid aber
mal ganz nett aber ehrlich von den 3000
6 und geräte jedes weiß dann über
nämlich den namen hier ok dann bitte
das nächste gerät
830 der fc sieber und zwar habe ich
gerade gemerkt dass die rolle nicht
genug wasser hat und deswegen tut am
anfang immer kurz stoppen 107 wenn das
nicht der fc ist lasse ich mich 100
prozent
[Gelächter]
100% fc 700 murat respekt es ist der fc
7 also nichts vormachen man merkt der
mann hat sie gelernt haben die hamburger
band und der ist richtig am marschweg du
bist richtig erledigt mein freund aus
kössen die lösung ich habe halt du bist
die zweite lösung mal richtig
applaus morath
ich glaube wir müssen die
schwierigkeiten ein bisschen erhöhen
bisher dem rad alles gewusst wie man
gespannt die nächste runde ein bisschen
anspruchsvoller morath spitzt die ohren
und ich würde sagen los geht's
ich will mir ganz ganz sicher und zwar
ich habe rollen gehört das ding wurde
geschoben und mit kurz vor als hätte ich
einen teller gehört das heißt es muss
irgendein gerät sein zum rollen
hundertprozentig hörsystem für geräusch
von dem
gegenwärtig tendiert zu einem
sonderbaren gerät was ein teller hat
aber ich weiß den namen jetzt gerade
nicht dafür ein guter trick aber wie
wird zu bezeichnen eine frage ist es aus
dem professional serie oder aus aus der
aus der home & garden serie den tipp
kann ich da geben es ist aus unserer
hormongaben serie home and garden serie
vor welches gerät habt ihr was man mit
dem teller hat ach ich bin so doof
teller natürlich und zwar ist es der
twin und 2u
der kirche hat das original gerät das
ding zu schieben dass sich dieses im
print wind hinter
der sich eine kehrmaschine ist es ja die
spezielle kehrmaschinen hd-kameras ja
das ging aus einer hand das nächste
gerät
der kompressor
sauge ich habe mir noch nicht und ich
wüsste ich das ist der fehler ja ich hab
so kam auch geräte verkauft
es ist ein staubsauger also dass das
gerät nicht hast dann müsse man auch mal
kurz mit ihr werde man einen halben
punkt vergeben oder sowas aber ein
staubsauger und nicht ganz so schlecht
unser neuer vcs sechs cordless gut das
nächste gerät bitte
ok folgendes
merkt euch eins das ist so geil und zwar
das ist an ein sauger der beutel hat
sich 100% beutel sei das ein beutel drin
das höher ist würden den beutel mann
austauschen und werkstatt ist wenn er
sich anschaut dass die luft sie der sich
100 prozent
es ist ein staubsauger mit beutel 100
prozent und zwar
der runde richtig hören geräusche das
ist der mit der mit der rundung ist 100%
der sich da
könnte es vielleicht sein als der b3
battery ist
wenn du
[Musik]
hast
du hast meinen applaus morath also ihr
seid so was man erledigt habe das
mitgekriegt hat der ist wohl
eins haben wir noch morath und
pillepalle mitgemacht ich ist dies eine
heckenschere kann es sein wobei ein
bisschen abkürzen ich denke heckenschere
körper stehen lassen klammer
heckenscheren im programm alles wird der
garten es ist unsere gsh 18 20 jahren
hat seine performance
[Applaus]
dafür ist eine meise jetzt zeige ich dir
du kannst philipp bist du bereit und
lang geputzt
einfach staubsauger klar da hatte
klassiker der fenster sorger kennt man
doch damit werden auch uns die fenster
gereinigt ja
[Applaus]
junge weitergeht bereichs zweite gerät
und bereit dann ton ab
und reicht ja
kenne ich
passt auch gut zu dem boden boden
reiniger aber nicht irgendeines der
premium hat wurden reiniger das kann
doch gar nicht hören die
unterschiedlichen prägungen germanisches
zu gehören jetzt kann ich es nicht
mitbekommen hast du jetzt die hartmann
10 jahre das hast du super gehört ihr
verarscht mich total sage ich dir nur
harpunen reiniger respekt philipp
freut uns natürlich dass auch du dich
mit unseren geräten auseinandersetzung
engagiert er ist auch die kamera der
sich noch nicht aus als ist ein
reinigungsgerät jemals in der hand kein
handy hier haben dafür kannst du werbung
für palmolive machen und ich dafür kann
es nur nicht verlieren passt mal auf
dann das nächste gerät bitte
eindruck ganz interessant
und zwar
dass eine kehrmaschine das hört mal bei
der praktisch über den boden läuft aber
das interessante ist ist es ist nicht
ein teller der sich dreht
es sind zwei dass nämlich der tun dass
die twin kehrmaschine
ich weiß nicht ob wir das team einige
umsetzung gemisch von ihr nicht
anzuhören ich weiß es nicht das gibt's
doch nicht also da an der stelle uns der
frage an die regie das gerät dadurch
optimal richtig erkannt aber in einer
rekordzeit wir haben bei mora damit
knapp zehn minuten gewartet erst
unterschied ich würde fast sagen es gibt
eine extra punkt
[Applaus]
sollte hier jemand nicht erwartet habe
der mars ist du und das tut noch erklärt
die gleiche funktioniert ich glaube ich
bin jedoch volle konzentration können
wir weitermachen
dann die kollegen bitte das nächste
gerät
da ist nicht lang also
ist nicht leicht aber
nachdenke bitte mach dich nicht so will
das ist brauch ich mache davon zehn irrt
nicht funktioniert ganz gut und zwar
sind trockensauger
das ist nicht irgendeiner war das hört
man nämlich beziehungsweise in cordless
der hat nämlich kein schnee mehr da sind
trocken also ein hand saugen die kann
man so führen und deshalb ohne schnur
über
was du machst es ist ja wohl nicht weißt
du gar nicht gibt es noch nicht wir
haben schon noch nicht die ich komme mir
vor wie
kassel er weiß noch nicht was ich
verarsche nicht offensichtlich schneider
bisher nicht mal ganz so schlecht ab
moran also ist die rheiner hamburg die
antwort philipp war nämlich absolut
richtig das haben wir zu hören
gutes gefühl brauchen auch das nächste
gerät philipp bitte nochmal
konzentrieren
ja
da hat sich
[Applaus]
das ist ein battery pack klar das merkt
man hört man doch mit dem volumen von
sagt ja klar
das ist richtig findet aber zum
monatsende reicht und da waren auch
ziemlich schnell klar war
philipp auch ein buch fertig
haben wir das letzte gerät dann bittet
olap
[Applaus]
heckenschere ganz klar warum
applaus applaus
[Musik]
kommt ist echt witzig finde es nie mehr
witzig jetzt zwei stellt mir sehr sehr
gute rolle habt ihr schon bei berlin tag
& nacht gespielt oder irgendwas das
gibt's ja
das gibt's doch nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
halt gleich
[Musik]
ein arzt mein arzt ist darf
und 9
die
huskies damit dieser muss
[Musik]
murat bevor wir uns hier noch leblos vom
sofa kippst die letzte denn es hat ja
schon relativ viel abverlangt haben wir
gedacht wir lassen einen arzt ein
fliegen sicher ist sicher aber er gesagt
challenge morath da mache ich mit also
der film machte jeden scheiß mit ihm
verstehe ich auch die theoretisch
menschen leben weil er sich mal heute
auch und dann denke ich mir was machen
wir mittags hier stuttgart regime eine
ein schnitzel wir haben noch eine
challenge vorbereitet wenn wir uns
umdrehen und in diese richtung schauen
es geht um laubbläser wettschießen bitte
an die laubbläser wir werden die
laubbläser um die fußbälle in die tore
zu befördern ganz wichtig ihr verwendet
nur die laubbläser und die power der
laubbläser das heißt ihr nutzt nicht das
rohr und lenkt die bälle sondern längst
nur mit dem luftstrom ich mache drei
zwei eins und dann geht es los okay
da versucht das drückt schon einer zu
bescheißen
was geht 3m
moment wir machen sein das will man sein
dass wir legen die laubbläser hin
stellen uns dahinter
und dann haben wir dann haben jetzt halt
auch ein sprint zu den laubbläsern aber
vielleicht besseren start
und
markdorf
denn fragte vor
das war gerade am rande der fairness
aber es hat richtig cool aussehen muss
man sagen murat das ging wohl für dich
ganz ganz knapp in die hose ich habe
keine place ich habe ja den punkt muss
man dem team sally zu schreiben aber
großartig wettkampf das war ganz große
sport wenn ihr gerade gezeigt habt
deswegen applaus aber beide
[Applaus]
also der faire sportsmann ja auch vorbei
ja genau er schiebt die tore durch die
gegend
schwansen außer puste erzählt er selber
geht
ok großartig schöne challenge
[Musik]
ja ja ja ja
ein garten herum liste zu leihen
[Musik]
ne-na de - vor der zieht es die meine
theorie vom scanner
[Musik]
habe ich nicht gezögert als ist sicher
wie bei kennt den film wie die
weihnachten die geister die ich rief und
alle 30 gekommen bestätigt den
verrückten der bekloppt gewalt und
logisch gekommen das gibt es noch nicht
es kann den zielraum der antifa erste
haben biologen das war dann philip ich
ziehe meine jahr haben wir mit challenge
vorbereitet hatten wieder sehr weil ich
habe keine freunde mehr als können
aber
ihr könnt es noch von früher die außen
wette so was in die richtung haben das
auch vorbereitet es geht das also nach
draußen
[Musik]
hier hinter uns sehen wir sehr um was
geht es hier haben labyrinth aufgebaut
darunter drei bälle und die drei bälle
müssen von da unten da oben rein wir
haben hier oben eröffnung
ihr müsst also mit dem hochdruckreiniger
die bälle von hier unten welchen weg er
wählt ist euch überlassen ob er alle
drei auf einmal nacheinander machen
wollte ist uns egal alle drei bälle
müssen am ende hier oben drin
verschwunden sein und ganz einfach der
dass am schnellsten geschafft hat von
euch beiden hat das ding gewonnen okay
wer von euch beide möchte anfangen ich
würde sagen du warst du fängst an oder
schere stein papier gespart wird kann
schon jetzt immer gespannt wie die smart
nicht schnack schnuck wie in guten alten
zeiten schwer
verständlich gemacht doch
erst
los also ran als gerade nicht scheitern
das ist einer jener zeit nimmt kann
man kurzen instruktion wie sowieso ein
stellen wieso ist doch ein
hochdruckreiniger du hast drei stufen du
hast die mix funktion die hard funktion
und dies oft funktion du kannst mit
einer pistole kannst du boosten plus -
wenn der druck zu wenig ist druck auf
plus wenn er zu viel isst druck auf -
vor einstellen das ist das heißt der
klägerin liefert oder arbeiten wollte
vorwärts loslegen ich habe gerade über
meinem knopf im ohr ausrichten noch eine
anweisung bekommen wir ändern ganz
kleines bisschen was im regelwerk wir
warten nicht so lange bis er alle bälle
drin habt sondern wir nehmen eine minute
zeit und schauen dann wie viel berlin
drin habt ihr noch 3 2 1 los
[Applaus]
[Musik]
weiter weiter weiter
[Applaus]
[Musik]
naja
und
das war's wohl aus die zeit 3 22 bälle
von drei versenkt ja schon mal ganz gut
vorgelegt ja ja okay okay dann ja dann
ihre hand vorgelegt zweibändiges
aufzuholen morath
331 und co
[Musik]
[Applaus]
respekt da ist noch zeit über
normalerweise meinte es mit
medizinbällen und fußball
gratuliere die
ski wir können auch mal szenen werden
versenken in der zeit so hast du vorne
aber schon gewusst was ist was du hast
ja auch eine andere düsen gemacht und
ich habe auf zwei gestellt naja spricht
für deinen kompetenzen sehen wir mal
unter dem gesichtspunkt erkennt eure
produkte
schon dies die wahl hat das ding nicht
rein ich aber das muss man neidlos
anerkennen ich bin ein fairer sportsmann
wer das war der punkt geht ein mord
[Applaus]
normalerweise sind der hälfte der zeit
geschafft habe mich immer als zwei
punkte bekommt wieder ein punkt ging
jetzt dann nicht nachrücken
kann die mail dienste aber komisch dass
sowohl athen wächst ist mir jetzt noch
mal musik kommt und dann kommt noch mal
in dem runter und schreit
[Musik]
ihr seid wie knackig
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
sie laden oft gar keine freunde mehr
[Gelächter]
super dass du da bist du bereit erklärt
haben sich ja anzutreten der challenge
gegen murat holzschlag den murat kaya
schon zwei drei challenges hinter sich
momentan stets eins zu zwei er könnte
jetzt gleichziehen möchte keinen druck
aufbauen morath
um teams elevator einführungszeiten
solltest du die nächste challenge
gewinnen es geht wieder draußen ab wir
haben uns vorbereitet es geht ein
wettrennen kehrmaschinen wir trennen
dann würde ich sagen gehen raus
[Musik]
gut zu unserer außen wetter hier steht
das gute stück mit dem ihr euch bettelt
kehrmaschinen wettrennen wir haben hier
ein parcours aufgestellt und da geht es
natürlich darum wer die bessere zeit
bisschen regelwerk haben ja wenn ihr so
ein hütchen umweht sind das extra fünf
sekunden ok es sollte also wirklich
schauen dass er sauber durchkommt
ansonsten wir nehmen die zeit und das
schnellere von euch gewinnen dass beides
erhalten ich hatte näherten fort also
eher ein vorteil er ist leichter wenn
ihm fehlt es hier
[Musik]
doch noch
19 71 19 71 euro und in den asphalt
gehämmert heidenreich sind wir gespannt
aber nicht gut gefahren ist er war waren
zu schlecht er war nicht schlecht
er starb erst gerade acht
[Musik]
täglichen leben
los
aber hat er das ico
dabei
[Musik]
das war
gewollt und gewünscht noch in allem
waren die werte ich als taktischer
beschissen ist so alles gibt er wusste
spielen radtour gute verlierer
das hat sich gelohnt warte jetzt keine
eigene das hier ist cup geschwader weg
man ua das hat echt
cool
gut nochmal ein punktsystem sally
alles aufholen es wird langsam eng jetzt
wird's langsam eng aber ich
kenne ich kann mir also es kann keine da
komme ich hier niemanden mehr wirklich
schauen wir mal
[Musik]
also alle freude die ich jetzt noch
alles im gefängnis es kann nicht sein
mein gott niemand verliert gegen seine
frau die machen richtig planten
[Musik]
ich mache
diesen job
[Musik]
wir haben uns gehen die kandidaten aus
aber ohne deine seine eigene frau jahr
gefällt dir jetzt im rücken seine frau
sie mir nicht mehr im paradies
[Musik]
sally gegen ward edu l es wäre
eigentlich eine ziemlich klare sache
bereits deswegen haben wir uns was
einfallen lassen wir verdoppeln denn
eins hat setzen dem spiel du hast also
die möglichkeit mit einem sieg in der
challenge system zumindest noch
gleichzuziehen und erzählte uns aussehen
habe ich geworden
deswegen hier steht unter wasser ich
mache mir folgen würde in unserem quiz
tisch
mit in den platz die regeln sind klar
der von euch die frage als erstes
weishaupt auf dem bagger hat dann fünf
sekunden zeit mir die antwort zu geben
wenn sie falsch ist geht der punkt
entschuldigen ich schätz fragen oder
sind es die ihre fragen zum antworten
dies sind fragen quer durch unsere tour
heute ich würde sagen so also für ein
bisschen unfair wenn einer schon denen
die hand auf dem bagger hat dass ihr
beide irgendwie so die hantieren an die
kante vielleicht an die kante gelegt und
dann die erste frage lautet wie lautet
die bezeichnung unseres weltbekannten
gelben farbton
er ist dann dann glaube ich dass das
ganze hier eine ganze nichts zu tun ich
habe es nicht nur einmal erzählen jahr
[Musik]
2013 von
gelb auf anthrazit von unseren bekannten
kirche gelb 13 18 cent gelb das ist wie
die mitternachts formel früher in der
schule wenn mich nachts der
geschäftsführer anruft dann wird mich
fragen was ist unsere farbe und dann
muss das wie aus der pistole geschossen
kommen also wenn das bei uns anfangen
möchte ist merkt das schon mal 13 18
[Applaus]
die zweite frage wann wurde das erste
gerät für privat privatkunden auf den
markt gebracht und wie hieß es
das weiß niemals
hd 555
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
also ich bin froh dass wir wenigstens
einer von euch beiden ein bisschen
zugehört hat auf der tour man muss nicht
immer wichtige dinge merken das ist
einmal die farbe krise uns allererste
gerät sowie beim ihr allererstes video
allererstes datum so dinge muss man sich
merken muss raus schossen kommen aus dem
effeff
über wie viele aktive patente aber
die hand ist noch draufzahlen du hast
gedrückt
605 diese falsche antworten möchten
es war es kommt an sally ist darf ich
sagen danke bitte erinnert euch zurück
peter spuhler zurück er hat freuen immer
im video sagt 650 und der dennis hat
glaubt firma 640 und ich hab gesagt 640
und hört einfach nicht so
beherrscht so dreht sich nach mit dem
nichts hinzufügen die 640 aktive partie
mehr kann man bitte zurückspulen an die
szene
und um möglichen patents zu machen viel
hat mir 650 640 aktive 6640 aktive
würden wir haben alle unsere kinder hast
du das ist nicht gefährlich was sie
heute läuft ich werde alles sagt meine
mutter hat immer gesagt entweder glaubst
oder glaubt es nicht aber schwerer darf
man aber
ehrlich sein wo er steht ja bist du
ehrlich ich bin in meiner linken war
schon immer ehrlich zu mir
[Gelächter]
jetzt geht es nochmal ein bisschen um
unsere firmengeschichte
angefangen haben die natur erinnert euch
die meilensteine unserer
firmengeschichte
und ganz am anfang
wo befand sich der erste firmensitz
richtig richtig moral einen punkt
danke morath also ich hab doch nicht
alles nur wand erzählt scheiße für mich
bricht keine welt zusammen hoffentlich
sehen auch viele die nächste frage
morath sally
welches war das erste bekannte denkmal
das im rahmen des kirche kultur
sponsoring es war ein die christus
statue in
brasilien
wichtig dass die christusstatue in rio
de janeiro
[Applaus]
stimmt dass jesus christus steht die aus
180 stimmt ist bestimmt in rio de
janeiro da stimmt ich habe aufgepasst
was du schöne maschine
du brauchst
sally hat kein name sie hat eine
maschine nummer
eure täglich gewesen in der schule neben
wir zu sitzen gemischt doch wie gewesen
das mäppchen hoch gemacht haben sagt
schau nicht ab ich war die die schon
immer für alle jemand gebacken hat
gut das war die letzte frage unseres
quiz da was was ja was ich nach ja
irgendwann ist das schönste spiel zu
ende das ging ganz knapp 3 zu 2 1 ali
und seines teams sagt murat
schade schade schade das war
das ganze team von heute
[Applaus]
tja pech im spiel glück in der liebe
oder tritt im spiel pech in der liebe es
passt auch sehr bestimmt welche in der
liebe ich habe verloren aber glück in
der liebe
hat es richtig gemacht
so hat jetzt geht es darum den
wetteinsatz einzulösen es ging darum
kirche ein draufgänger ja gut wenn du
gewonnen und hätte selber darüber können
wir reden können aber du hast verloren
es sei froh dass wir immerhin
kehrmaschine von uns bekommst
der auftrag ist klar der parkplatz hier
geht von da bis hinter das gebäude rund
zweieinhalb tausend menschen brauchen
platz brauchen war es beim parkplatz
bauen das sauberen parkplatz vor allem
weil unsere sich aufs handy geschickt
weil der sommer ja das glaube ich und da
freut es uns umso mehr dass du den job
übernimmt du kennt sich aus mit der
maschinen kann sich nicht mehr erklären
brauche ich nichts merken le clos
handvoll tank ich vorher war super
morath las krachen
wir sehen uns dann wohl sehen uns morgen
übermorgen weiß wenn ich morgen früh
kommen schöne parkplatz wer sauber
moment geht alle da
[Musik]
romantisch so romantisch ja ich habe
auch meine augen so dass kleine dicke
kind ist auf
geschossen haben
und dass die flip die maschinen kennt
das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
und die zeit
verlieren wir wollen eine scheitern
sehen ich weiß ich hab keine freunde mir
egal ich habe es gern
[Gelächter]
[Musik]